toi tu es là c'était humiliant avez vous
déjà été enfermé dans une pièce seul
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça va être le cas
on va tous ensemble enfermé dans une
toute petite pièce et on va devoir
trouver un moyen de s'en échapper c'est
ce qu'on appelle une escape room ça
existe dans la vraie vie avec a eu
l'idée d'en faire une dans la réalité
virtuelle the va kate room star on y va
au quai nous voici dans la pièce elle
est extrêmement petit on va pas sans
dire vous voyez donc gérer ça va devoir
trouver un code pour l'ouvrir à temps et
jusqu'à une lampe torche on verra
beaucoup mieux que ça on va devoir
trouver une clé ici aussi on doit
retrouver une clé à moi je suis à
l'affût aa
j'ai trouvé une note je suis toujours là
même si je suis venu par moi même donc
tu es venu ici par toi même c'est quand
même bizarre s'enfuir d'ici ne semble
plus possible
alors ici on a une punaise mais que ça
va jamais nous servir c'est un truc de
ouf voilà alors comment on peut faire
pour évoluer là dedans au ça ça va nous
servir mon dieu ça c'est un barreau de
laon messala des tableaux ouais bon mais
qu'on va retourner tout ça on va pas se
mentir une boule en polystyrène des
livres on va pas commencer à tout le
beau [ __ ] mais qui bordaient le
discret rien ou que dis-je
que dis-je [ __ ] la neige les casser on
a une clé ici mais qu on a une clé alors
est-ce que baugé a priori ces décrets de
ça oui oui monsieur o
c'est quoi ce avec alors à en juger
abattant skis ça c'est faux pas de
simplement
abonnés du coup il nous en reste cinq à
trouver alors ici un carton ici aux
attentes c'est pas en ville à ce qui se
passe deuxième truc que je retiens
andrew un tube donc c'est bien ce que je
pensais les autres tubes doit être caché
dans la pièce ah ok donc le bleu pour
allumer la lumière bleu et le rouge et
le jaune pour allumer la lumière
mika a changé alors j'aimerais juste
lâché cette lampe mais je suis pas aidé
niqab alors c'est ici mes compagnes s'il
ya un truc mika je reste sur cette
position est humain certes habite à as
tu ne touche pas à mon bull hockey a du
coup il nous en manque encore 3 regarde
là bas y en a un mec six trous lui il ya
un [ __ ] dalo de lumière oui le violet
val là où il ya de la lumière comme un
mec ça doit être caché derrière non la
wii
hop
il nous en manque un un dernier à mais
le pc s'est allumée en fait j'ai accès
aux pc maintenant ok on dirait que je
suis enfermé dans cette pièce
comment j'ai fait pour m'en sortir
peut-être que j'ai laissé un indice
quelque part alors ici on a une punaise
mais que ça va jamais nous servir c'est
un truc de ouf c'était sous notre nez
depuis le début mika
un code 14 500 4 j'ai dit quoi [ __ ] la
mémoire de merde 14 h
oui alors on a quoi troubler clé
trouvent les plombs trouvent les lettres
et ensuite grimper l'échelle allant du
coup on a une clé qui fait probablement
la taille de mes yep
on va là mais bon c'est ça oui les skis
compte de la vraie vie souvent fait à à
la moitié à peu près des sleepings taxe
est une nouvelle pièce parce que tu as
réussi comme la débloquer enfin bref non
sinon c'est une cheminée mais condamné
north bay de la pièce on a ce truc et on
a il y avait maintenant tout ce temps
moi je ne voulais plus voir quiconque
maintenant je veux voir des gens mais je
n'arrive
non non je me voir avec quelqu'un mais
je ne pense pas que je puisse mais si tu
peux quand on veut on peut mettre c'est
quoi ça à sète lympia pas grande
ampoules dedans est ce que ce serait pas
oui au mj croyez pas que je passe toutes
les lettres de suture pense d'une
maquette il ya un code à 4 chiffres
le sale [ __ ] il aima la [ __ ] thème
qu'est ce que je suis je suis très bien
organisée je sais parfaitement où il a
coiffé tout comme dans ma chambre tu
vois un truc tu n'y a rien de cacher un
n'importe quoi tu m'as donné une théorie
péter peut-être les en attente est
rempli et c'est quand tu fais une
friperie à plein temps fallait faire
s'affaler empilés et comme ça on voyait
les théories de merde mais qu attend on
l'a oublié cette petite lettre
finalement il y avait une part de vérité
dans ce que tu disais mis ko mais quand
je m'approche safe code 2 8 7 4 allée de
8 7 4 olala un guitariste un cas le
dernier plomb mais pas du tout on a une
lettre et une carte de fidélité fnac
je dois arrêter de me cacher la vraie
vie c'est dehors je dois m'en aller
d'ici et du coup avec ça qu'est ce que
je fais à un mec c'est pas mal de jeunes
entreprises n'est pas alimenté c'est ça
il est pas alimenter mais qu il nous
manque un fusible
il nous manque un fusible [ __ ] il est
mort d'anwar alors dans les eskers prom
souvent rien ne doit dépasser un mètre
soixante dix bougies moyens aériens au
dessus de moi mes mecs mais mais qu'ils
ont trahi la règle du mas de soixante
dix mecs qui vont du coup on a le
dernier mot mais salah et là je suis
presque voilà ça s'allume rouge du coup
on prend notre carte de fidélité fnac et
voilà du coup c'est assez ouvert et là
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va choper
ça oh c'est quoi cette lettre mais qu
elle est tombée nos fait qu'il ya des
choses qui apparaissent qui faisait que
c'est escape room je les fais j'ai
trouvé le chemin pour s'en aller d'ici
si je veux m'échapper delà de la pièce
j'ai juste à retirer le casque htc boys
pour de bas c'est ça la chute mais non
c'est une connerie regard mais qu'il y
avait un cadenas regarde ça là pour s'en
aller il ya aussi ça là on va faire un
truc a pris le frein on va faire de la
soudure mon gars allen la chaleur de la
poule à non mes mecs te fout pas mayotte
et aux as s'il vous plaît domb un mec je
pose salah beau c'est bon il marche
pizza à meymac ses poèmes quand il
trouvera la paix est un pion que les
objets sont réels mais c'est fort bon
bah du coup c'est la fin du jeu
excellent de chute abonnez-vous je me
casse c'est qu'en fait c'est une
métaphore tu cherche à sortir de la
pièce mais en fait pour sortir de la
pièce c'est tout bête s'il faut faire il
faut retirer le casque et du coup qui
n'est plus dans la pièce située dans le
monde réel c'est une belle métaphore une
manière de
de se faire trois euros par bandes sur
un jeu passe et ouf quoique certaines
n'étaient pas là mais ça vous a plu en
moi j'ai adoré le jeu je trouve ça super
malin de faire des eskers prouve mais
dans la réalité virtuelle et puis
j'espère surtout qu'un jour on pourra
faire ça avec des amis en ligne dans la
même pièce
c'est tous avec notre acheter weill
c'est un peuple aussi à la tenue
prochaine des commerces ont regardé
portez vous bien chat au monde pis